[Music]
welcome back i'm joined now by today's
pfac team talk tv's international editor
isabelle oakshot and author bonnie grier
and associate editor of the spectator
and author douglas murray uh who i guess
is you in new york douglas
i am indeed so from your lofty uh
scenario over there in new york looking
back at your mother country here a lot
of things that have been bubbling here
big and i wouldn't mind just getting
your take on that from new york uh first
of all i don't know if you heard that
interview just now with mick lynch
about the strikes coming next week but
it does feel like a real throwback this
to the 70s and 80s you know the old you
know
militant union bosses holding the
country to ransom i just can't help
feeling it's so ill-timed to be doing
this right now
i couldn't agree more i listened to the
interview of great interest
because like everybody else in britain i
have had an experience plenty of times
in my life of what happens when the rail
unions go on strike and you know what it
means is that everybody trying to get
into their place of work has the most
miserable time imaginable uh i've done
it myself countless numbers of times
when the unions strike you end up having
to stand for hours at a bus stop to get
onto a massively overcrowded bus and
travel for hours to do a journey that
would normally take you maybe half an
hour and so every time this happens
public sentiment against the unions
grows i can just i can assure you and
many of your viewers will appreciate
this nobody stands under somebody else's
armpit on a massively overcrowded bus
for hours and thinks happily about the
rail unions nobody thinks yeah those
guys should get a way above inflation
pay rise nobody thinks that well that's
nobody thinks
bonnie greer is raising her hand i stand
under people's armpits and i don't have
a problem with that i think probably
civilized society
well it's true and i used to live in new
york too so i can say that part of uh
civilized society is that workers should
be able to withhold
their labor and that's we need organized
labor i have no problems with this at
all even though even though it is
hurting people i admit that it is
hurting no problems with it really no i
really they want an eleven percent paid
they they i they probably deserve it
they don't deserve why don't they do
that
driver who may be earning 54 000 pounds
or more a year right now in this
economic climate deserve an eleven
percent well i mean could barely get one
well that's that's i can't go into a
technical thing about a train driver but
that is a very that's a skill 54
and in fact he admitted they were more
well that that's an important job i
don't mind them getting a lot of
livestreams saving lives driving
he's getting you're sitting there
but he's
well that's
ridiculous right then any worker can ask
you
just go yeah you can have it isn't it i
would actually isabelle douglas do you
want douglas
actually i just wanted to point out but
bonnie said that it's a skilled job but
she then said it's an important job it
is an important job it's not a skilled
job and there's one way to tell that
bonnie you or i could become a train
driver if we trained but you or i could
not just become a brain surgeon tomorrow
could we right what i got to do is being
a trained driver well the point being
it's not that skilled at all no well
we're gonna we're gonna compare brain
surgery to a training well let's go back
what i would compare is brain surgeons
to this and anyone working in the
hospital you care but you can't put it
in
there
it's so unskilled that guess what we can
actually get driverless trains and that
is what we should be looking to do this
is a long-term investment there's no
quick fix here but these guys are
basically talking themselves out of a
job their pay packages are pretty
generous i've looked at the fine print
there have been various good newspaper
exposes of that in recent days i mean
many many people in this country would
absolutely love those jobs and frankly
if i were interested
these people are driving trains i have i
have no problem with giving people
driving trains what they want no problem
that's a ridiculous attitude
so you get whatever you want i i look i
i am interested in safety i'm interested
in what if workers need to have a play
rise in this climate i don't know when
they landed i don't think it is i don't
know when they left i don't think the
priority right have nothing against
train drivers by the way i don't get the
train that often when i do it's an okay
experience it used to be much more
enjoyable driving on the train it's not
enjoyable anymore um they you know they
run late they have poor records now on
the server
well i just think it's not an experience
it used to be it's not that enjoyable
well you know hacking people in sardines
on smaller characters it's not their
problem it's not their fault donnie your
argument just seems to be because they
want to pay rise they should get a pay
raise i mean what are you going to apply
that to every single worker in this
country and if so they can have whatever
they want i think they're going to be
paid for you know whatever you want it's
bankruptcy you're going to pay for the
pay rises is it going to be millions of
passengers
so what are you saying exactly that i'm
saying that your argument is utterly
absurd that they should have a pay rise
because they want it and you think that
they should have whatever they want i
think i think that the the the basic
premise of this is i'm for workers i
guess that's what's cool
women hang on i guess i guess that's
what i'm saying that we wanted to sit
around and talk about should they get 12
percent do they get 13 i don't know i'm
for workers
if a worker if a worker goes out that's
all that they have for one
for a bankrupt country which is where
your philosophy i'm afraid would take us
douglas i want to bring
the other raging story of the week is of
course rwanda i'm interested in your
take douglas on on what you think about
it it seems to me this is a completely
doomed policy that whether you agree
with the principle behind it it's just
not going to happen
well it it that's possible that it won't
happen i i support the policy i support
us having borders i support stopping and
uh dissuading people from engaging in
illegal migration into the country and
nobody who's criticized roy the policy
has yet come up with a better policy of
what to do to stop the illegal migration
at the south coast
but you're right piers it may well not
happen of course the first plane didn't
end up taking off this week
and why because of the echr and i think
by the way i wrote this last week in the
sun i said that and i've said many times
in the last few years there was always
going to come a day when the british
people realized that we had left the
customs union and other aspects of the
eu but we remained under the
jurisdiction of european law
now the echr and the european court that
enforces it
was the mechanism by which various
people made sure that the plane couldn't
leave to rwanda this week the british
courts approved it
but the uh various activists lawyers and
trade unions and others went to use the
echr and that was why the flight was
blocked so here's the thing i think here
this is a massive political um car crash
that's been waiting to happen for a long
time the government did not bother to
address the issue of the echr in recent
years and now the british public are
getting to see something that should
have been completely predictable which
was that we have remained and do remain
still under the jurisdiction of elements
of european law yeah and that is not why
we left the eu we did not land of course
at this point all the smart houses say
oh well the echr is different from the
eu that's true but nevertheless the idea
of brexit was we get back control of our
borders of our sovereignty and the right
to make our own laws you know my problem
with brexit
we don't have that uh doctors my problem
with brexit and i voted remain but then
i also voted for boris johnson at the
election because he was the only leader
prepared to deliver the results of the
referendum and i believe that democracy
and honoring democratic votes was more
important than my personal feelings i've
got to say though i tweeted yesterday to
a huge response at some stage
we are going to have to start seeing
some benefits from brexit sure and if we
don't you know the the the jungle drums
beating to try and maybe overturn it
with future governments they're going to
get louder because right now it's very
hard to point to anything and say well
look brexit's working
well i think that's true i think that i
mean i don't agree that nothing is good
from the last few years it's been a very
unusual time and of course don't forget
the moment we left the eu
we immediately went into a global
pandemic and turned down so it's
extremely hard actually to work that
stuff out i do maintain though the main
reason the british public voted for
brexit was that we were told i think
with with honesty and and accurately
that we could make sure that we could
become a sovereign country again in
charge of our own borders in charge of
our own okay
america is like other countries let's
not leave the impression that this was
an overwhelming vote for brexit this was
pretty much this was very narrow
it was over 17 and a half million people
exactly but it was one of the biggest
votes in the history right but it was a
narrow result and the fact that
something like this was decided on a
simple yes one person could have decided
brexit or the simple majority is absurd
and people like me visiting
i don't think i don't think i don't yeah
i don't think you can revisit it
i do think though that the call down the
line
for another referendum will get louder
if there are no benefits to be seen from
brexit actually i'm going to surprise
you by agreeing with you on that and i'm
probably going to annoy a bunch of
brexiteers i mean now we've got to make
brexit work it's supposed to be an
opportunity by the way i want it to work
now that we've pressed this button as a
country i respect people's opinions
it wasn't so funny rather than ranting
no i'm not granting it
you're absolutely right the whole
country needs to see everybody including
those that didn't vote for brexit
because in the end we're all in this
together
needs to see tangible benefit and among
those is going to have to be leaving the
european court of human rights and now
the government has the perfect
opportunity to do that i think everybody
can get i think we haven't seen any
tangible benefits yet i didn't say we
hadn't seen any tangible benefits i said
that we've got to see brexit as an
opportunity i want to get one other
subject in here bonnie and you know
it's it's a touchy one yeah because i
told you i wasn't going to deal with
this subject
but i actually in itself that response i
think is unacceptable it is exciting i
tell you what i'll tell you no no i'm
excited i'll tell you why so the story
behind this is that tonight in the sun
they're going to rev up but real a story
that uh sanji javid the health secretary
uh has apparently told nhs bosses that
they have to rescind what they've been
doing on the nhs website which is
removing all gender-specific language
particularly in fact exclusively about
women and what they were doing was on
the guidance for women about health
issues involving various cancers
specific to women ovarian cancer
cervical cancer and so on they removed
any mention of women and they did this
to appease the trans activist lobby to
appease them right now i tell you why
it's a miscalculation i've written a
column about this tonight for the sun on
the back of it because if you are a
trans woman
so you're a biological male who
transitions and becomes a trans woman
under the new rules which came in last
year you can have new medical records
established under your new self-identity
but that means you don't get
automatically called for screening for
the specific diseases pertaining to your
biological sex and that is actually
going to put people's lives at risk well
and that's my problem okay this is the
first other than the fact that there's a
war on hang on calling women this is the
first time i've heard this is extremely
complicated and you've laid it out as it
should be laid out
but i think that for the health
secretary who's a layman just like you
and me to actually make a directive
against doctors that part is wrong and i
don't i don't know why no no no he's not
no he's a politician he's elected he's a
politician that's an official in charge
of elsewhere no
hang on he's a politician doctors made
the decision
not in this country
the health service is not run by doctors
and that may be news to you
it's running by politicians
wait a minute wait a minute oh my god
i'm not talking about who runs it if the
hell is i'm going to make the assumption
it's about can i speak well thank you
all right you speak i'll sit in and
listen to you fine all right let me
let me just put another point of the
column i wrote which is about we did
this on the show yesterday briefly i
looked more into it so the burgess hill
girls school in west sussex the head
teacher came out the headmistress and
she said we're not going to use the word
girls anymore
and the school's name remains burgess
hill
girls school she also said she was now
reviewing whether to ever use the word
daughter in correspondence to parents
lest it cause offence and yet if i
looked at the website which i did today
for burgess hill girls school the very
first paragraph talks about we're going
to turn your young girls into wonderful
women in other words to get the money
from the parents to enroll their kids at
the school they the headmistress herself
that i think this whole thing is utterly
absurd but i think that you made a
actually a really good point which i
would imagine is going to be quite hard
for people to argue against over this
issue of whether they have what their
health records say right in terms of
being called up for screening but what
about this whole thing of um you know
men coming in for screening and asking
whether they could be pregnant i think
that's going to be like an insult
to something i have a family member who
is transitioning right in a very
difficult situation right i completely
support her
her i completely support her and i think
this conversation now i hear what you're
saying but it is extremely complicated
it's extremely kind of she's not that
comfortable it is complex yes it is no
it's not because yes it is yesterday let
me explain why yes it is and i'm telling
you this okay as a woman i think this is
complicated i think what's happened is
that unfortunately in the in the
promotion of trans rights which i
support to fairness and equality there
are new inequalities and unfairness is
being created and the main one for me
when you degender all this language
around women and girls when you say
you're not allowed to use the word girls
in a girls school when the nhs removes
the word women from from specific
guidance
to women about women's diseases
particularly
about gendering that's what you're
saying yes you know as a writer that all
kinds of titles have been de-gendered in
our lives i don't agree with most well
that's different well that's different i
think it's a war on the use of it but
that's different and i'm telling you
words have been degenered in my lifetime
and you know that people i don't use the
actual i don't use word actress anymore
but i can't even get on a plane with
british airways anymore and hear the
familiar words ladies and gentlemen
because somebody goes i'm offended well
don't what about the rights of all the
people who want to become a lady or a
gentleman
about it i never wanted to be called a
lady and that was before this whole
thing i want to be called a judge i
never wanted to be called a lady